hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well in book one of
his on the ends Cicero has torquatus
present the epicurean position and argue
for it part of that is going to be the
nature and the value of the virtues and
so each of the cardinal virtues wisdom
justice temperance and courage is going
to be considered wisdom is particularly
central and the epicurean position on
wisdom as indeed with the other virtues
is that it's not something that is
valuable in its own right it is valuable
precisely in that it conduces to living
a life that includes as much pleasure as
possible and that includes as little
pain as possible so wisdom helps us out
to live the good life but wisdom is not
itself you could say a component of the
good life although the Epicureans are
you know a little bit back and forth on
this because if you if you look at what
their good life consists then a lot of
it includes doing the activities that
fit under wisdom but the the basic
position as opposed to many other virtue
theories is that virtues is
the wisdom are valuable in you know in
light of pleasure in pain if there
wasn't any pleasure in pain to be
endured or enjoyed then we wouldn't
actually need wisdom wisdom is not
valuable in itself it doesn't have any
inherent goodness so why would the
Epicureans say that well torquatus
begins by saying that wisdom helps us to
deal with the central problem in life
and what is that he says it is ignorance
of good and evil so the great disturbing
factor in human life is ignorant of
these mistaken ideas about these
frequently robbed us of our greatest
pleasures you know what would he mean by
that well sometimes we think of
pleasures as being shameful as not being
the sort of things that we ought to
indulge in or human beings ought to
indulge in at all and so we rob
ourselves of them or we listen to you
know people's disparaging of them and we
also get ourselves into a lot of trouble
for pursuing the wrong kinds of them you
know if we if we think that some things
are more pleasurable than they really
are perhaps because our culture is
telling us that they're constantly being
portrayed to us as you know deeply
pleasurable then we might ignore things
that are actually a greater pleasure
some prime examples of this you know if
you grow up within a society that
stresses having as many sexual partners
as possible as being the sign of living
the good life right then you might
actually miss out on the greater
pleasures that are involved with some
sort of monogamous intimacy or if you
you know watch beer commercials for
example you get the idea that you know
every time that a game is on you should
be drinking and eating as much as
possible and you know jumping around
with your companions on your couch and
it might actually be more pleasurable
just to have
a beer and read a good book so you know
we get mistaken ideas and wisdom helps
us to straighten things out that way and
he also stresses another part mistaken
ideas about good and evil also torment
us with the most cruel pain of mind
people are afraid of all sorts of things
that aren't really you know necessary
for them to fear some of this falls
under courage as well as we'll talk
about elsewhere but being able to
understand what truly is good and what
truly is evil helps us to make better
decisions helps us to prioritize helps
us to gear carry out means and reasoning
so you could say rationality for us
human beings is dependent upon wisdom he
also talks about wisdom taking away
fears and the word that he uses there is
actually things that we are afraid of
and he says
terror or you know great fears and
appetites COO pitty toss we you know
it's not as if we shouldn't have any
fear whatsoever from the Epicurean point
of view but many of the things that we
fear we unnecessarily fear and so that's
not helpful for us likewise many of the
things that we have appetite or desire
for are not going to be particularly
conducive to us either I mean think
about the plethora of foodstuffs that we
can enjoy at least in the first world
because we have you know entire
industries catering ttan you could you
could you know sit in your place and eat
ice cream all day long that would be
pleasurable but it sure as hell wouldn't
be good for you in the long run
so another thing wisdom helps take away
our errors and prejudices ideas that
we've gotten from you know our
experience from other people from the
culture that turned out to be wrong and
then now more on the positive side
wisdom is a guide to attaining pleasures
we can actually cultivate this as a
virtue according to the Epicureans and
we will be better and better at
selecting the options in front of us
that lead us to a real pleasant life
overall and to pursuing the right kinds
of pleasures
another thing that torquatus talks about
this is absolutely central to the
epicurean philosophy is the
classification of desires so the the
Epicurus this goes all the way back to
him
classified desires into three classes
there are desires that are natural and
necessary there are desires that are
natural but not necessary there are
desires that are neither natural nor
necessary and an example of this you
have to eat food that's natural and
necessary eating a nice steak natural we
certainly have you know food receptors
in our mouths that that conduced to
enjoying that experience even even
vegans could enjoy a good steak although
they might have you know ethical
problems on the side being served on
gold plate neither natural nor necessary
right and a good pizza could also be
something that is natural but not
necessary you don't have to have a pizza
you could have something else that would
also be good now the real problem for
Epicureans comes in where we're dealing
with the the sort of desires and sort of
pleasures that are neither natural nor
necessary and those are what the
Epicureans call empty or vain desires
chaos is the greek for that those are
the ones that cannot truly be satisfied
and so as he says here the desires are
incapable of satisfaction what do you
mean there is the desires that are
neither natural nor necessary and this
leads to conflict they ruin not
individuals but whole families they
often shake the foundations of the state
it is
they that are the source of hatred
quarreling strife of sedition and war
nor do they block the only flaunt
themselves abroad or turn their blind
ion's on slots solely against others
even when prisoned within the heart they
quarrel and fall out among themselves
and this cannot but render the whole of
life embittered so if our life centers
around desires that are not natural and
not necessary to us we are actually
going to wind up being sort of a
battleground of conflicting desires and
wisdom would tell us hey we've got a
nice classification here indulge these
desires don't indulge these desires
strip these away avoidance of desires
for pleasures that are neither natural
or necessary thus becomes part of the
epicurean virtue of wisdom another thing
that he says wisdom can help us do
that's quite important is deal with
fortunes injuries and he uses the word
in urea there and it helps to lead us to
tranquility the the Epicureans and Greek
expressed this as octave axia not being
troubled sister Oh uses the word
tranquilly talks in Latin which is what
we can translate as peacefulness or
contentment or tranquility so wisdom as
a virtue as something cultivated within
oneself
is going to be valuable from the
epicurean perspective for all of these
reasons that we've talked about because
it's going to make us so we use a
synonym of wisdom it's going to make us
more prudent in deciding which pleasures
to select and to pursue and enjoy and
which to set aside which desires to say
no to and also which pains need to be
endured at least for the moment in order
to lead to greater pleasures later on
and which pains we can avoid in which we
can even see to be generated by
ourselves in the ways that we think
about things so by that
sort of
reasoning wisdom would become the most
important of the virtues for an
epicurean but it's not valuable in its
own right
you